♪♪
-Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Will Ferrell
and Chad Smith!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Cheering, applause continue ]
Chad, uh, Will...
[ Laughter, applause ]
I-I heard...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know that you guys
kind of look alike.
I did not know that you --
you dress similar --
[ Laughter ]
...you dress alike as well.
Uh, I'm honored to be hosting
this, uh --
hopefully, uh, this --
this end to this epic battle.
I mean, you guys were upset,
and I just...
[ Laughter ]
You're almost too angry to talk,
and I understand.
Um, can I just set the sta--
[ Laughter ]
Can I just set the stage --
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
I want to set the stage.
Chad, I know --
Chad, I can feel the heat
coming off of your bodies,
the anger and the...
-Uh-huh. Right.
-...the pent-up rage
and confusion.
-Yeah.
-Uh, but...
-He's an impostor.
-All right.
Chad, let's not --
Let's not start off like this.
I mean, this is --
Here's what happened.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. Who are you talking to,
Will or Chad?
[ Laughter ]
I'm talking to Will.
-Yeah.
-Now, Will...
-Yeah?
[ Laughter ]
-...this whole thing started --
You were on a Reddit AMA --
uh, February 4th.
Someone mentioned
that you look like Chad Smith
from The Red Hot Chili Peppers.
-I had heard that.
-Yeah.
And you responded by saying,
uh...
You said, "No.
[ Laughter ]
I am Chad Smith."
-That is true.
You are --
-And it's not true, 'cause...
he's not me.
[ Laughter ]
-But you said that you --
it's a character that you --
that Will Ferrell created
called Chad Smith.
-Correct.
-Yeah.
-And I was -- I was so pissed.
[ Laughter ]
-What did you do?
Do you remember where you were
when you heard that news?
-Yeah.
I was jammin'.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-You were jammin' --
-I was jammin' with the --
with the Chili Peppers,
with my guys.
Yeah. In our --
At our jam house.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You have -- How many jam houses
do you guys have?
-In America?
[ Laughter, applause ]
-In -- Yeah.
In America.
-Four.
-You have four.
So this --
You're at jam house number...
-Three.
-...three, and you're --
And you see this thing online.
-I go through the roof.
-Yeah. You just went...
-I'm like, "Flea, this is..."
[ Laughter ]
-You talked to Flea first.
-Yeah.
I go, "Flea, this is bull.
I'm tired of this."
-You're tired of this crap.
-I'm tired of being --
not getting enough respect
as Chad Smith.
-He seems like he's
a little angry, but yeah.
-Chad...
-I'll be honest.
I'm a little high right now.
-All right. No, no.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Chad, we'll bleep all this out.
Uh...Chad, when did you --
-My Chad Smith Go Juice
right here.
[ Laughter ]
-What is in the Chad --
the Chad Smith Go Juice?
What's that made of?
Can you tell?
-It's a chemical compound,
uh, that we make up
at the jam house -- number two.
[ Laughter ]
-The chemical compound.
-Yeah.
-All right. Understood.
Chad, how long
have you been playing drums?
-I've been playing since I was,
uh...since I was 8.
[ Laughter ]
-You remember where you were?
-Yeah.
In my house.
[ Laughter ]
-What room?
-Uh, in -- in my bedroom.
-You were in the bedroom.
You had a drum set there?
-Little, uh, Kmart drum set.
-Aw.
You just started jammin' out?
-Yeah, I just started jammin'.
I knew I had a gift.
-Yeah.
I mean, most likely, you know...
[ Laughter, applause ]
Yeah.
And, Will, how long have you
been playing the drums?
-I do not play the drums.
-Okay. Now...
[ Laughter ]
-Chad, what do the bandmates
think about this?
What does...
-Uh, you know,
they want me to, you know,
tear this guy a new one,
and, uh, they're like,
"Enough is enough."
It's affecting our shows.
Uh, it's affecting
the camaraderie in the band.
-Why?
-They said, "We're starting
to get brainwashed.
We look back. We think that's
Will Ferrell playing drums."
-The band actually thinks
they're playing
with Will Ferrell.
-Exactly.
-[ Sighs ] It's ridiculous.
-Will, this is
the weirdest thing.
But you're raising money
for charity with this drum-off.
Will, your charity
is CancerForCollege.org.
-Yes.
-And, Chad,
yours is LittleKidsRock.org.
-Yeah.
-So at least there's some, uh,
light at the end of this.
-We take instruments away
from children.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, how is that a good --
-We take them to a-a junkyard,
and we destroy them
in front of the children.
-And just show -- Really?
What...
-No.
-He doesn't know
what he's talking --
That can't be
what that is raising money for.
Little Kids R-- I think
you're giving instruments --
-It's my charity. Chad Smith.
[ Laughter ]
-Chad, you're, like, coming off
as a mean dude, man.
I thought it was
a different charity
where you actually
give instruments to schools.
-It started out that way.
[ Laughter, applause ]
But Cancer for College?
That's a great charity.
-Yeah.
-It is.
It started with my good friend.
I've had great success,
and it's a small charity,
but it's grassroots and it's
great that we can do this.
-But Little Kids Rock,
you think, is...
-Well, no.
Little Kids Rock, you know,
they shouldn't take instruments
from kids.
-They shouldn't.
-They shouldn't...
-What's wrong --
Why would you do that?
-...but we do,
and we've got a lot of support.
-[ Laughing ]
A lot of support.
-Who's supporting that?
-You'd be surprised.
-Junkyards.
-Guys, enough --
enough small talk.
I mean, I think you can feel
the crispiness in the air,
the energy that's here.
-Yeah.
-You know what the audience
wants.
You know what I want.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What America wants.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-It's time to find out
once and for all
who's the better drummer --
Will Ferrell
or the drummer from The Red Hot
Chili Peppers, Chad Smith.
You guys ready to do this?
-We are, and --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We were tricking you
that whole time.
This is Chad Smith,
and I'm Will Ferrell, actually.
-You got to be kidding me.
-Yeah.
So just so we know
who's really doing the drumming.
-You know what that means.
Let's bring out the drums
right here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Drum-off!
[ Drums beating ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right. Now just...
All right.
And that's Will.
Okay. Very good.
Now...
Oh.
Holy mackerel. Uh...
[ Bass drum playing,
crowd cheering ]
Seem about right?
-Yeah.
-Seem about right?
[ Laughter ]
All right, guys.
You know the rules.
Uh, this is a traditional
drum-off.
[ Laughter ]
-This is a traditional drum-off?
-What's that?
-Tonight we're gonna go
by traditional rules.
[ Laughter ]
This is a traditional drum-off.
You each get four solos.
Uh, whoever whacks, smacks, and
slaps the skins the best wins.
So without further ado,
let the drum-off begin!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's go, Will!
[ Crowd cheering ]
-Ladies first!
-Take notes, Chadwick.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
And that's how it's done.
-All right.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Take that, funny man!
[ Hi-hat clangs ]
-Looks -- Looks like baby
learned how to pway the dwums.
[ Laughter ]
But can baby do this?
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I just blew my mind.
-You just blew your mind?
-I just blew my mind.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
[ Snare drum thuds ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Come on.
Let's see what you got.
-You know what?
-What do you got?
-That was -- That was cute.
Do you play
for The Lukewarm Chili Peppers?
[ Laughter, applause ]
[ Snare thuds, cymbal crashes ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Cymbal crashes ]
Roll the credits.
Stop the show.
[ Laughter ]
-Chad?
-Go to commercial.
[ Laughter ]
I want to go to commercial.
-Chad...
-All right.
-...do you have a response?
-Roll the credits.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Crowd cheering ]
[ Cheers and applause ]